hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to one Finger Death Punch a
game suggested to me by you guys and one
that I had to play after I saw the
trailer for it if you guys remember way
back when there was these animations by
this guy named sow sow xiao xiao and
they were like stick fighting awesome
animations around new grounds i think
but either way it's supposedly at austin
kungfu fighting game that even mush will
not the bus and mash that even I can
play because it only does played by two
buttons cannot move in this game okay go
ahead for enemies to enter the zone
whatever you say bruh I'm waiting to win
it I am with it and go to me as I
entered the zone okay
notice how the great enemies take one
hit press the left mouse button it all
kennedys to approach you I can see one
oh there we go
I like it for I missed so we'll tell
Morpheus I know come to bow bow [ __ ]
get out of here holy crap this is
awesome wanna go faster lift alright oh
my god who's your son push push push
oh my god this is amazing cursor can be
anywhere on the screen okay whatever I'm
not even listening to what that guy's
saying about me oh my god then I missed
how did I miss I've no idea what is
going on he single peds you open to
enemy attacks it does not to miss I will
try I will do you proud master oh oh I
am going to like this game a lot I can
tell this is kind of like a this is
disco dodgeball levels of Awesome right
here because it's so simple it's so
simple it's such an easy concept and yet
it is so epic I haven't even gotten into
the game it's only the first part of it
- I gotta be patient it's it not the
button mash those more any other
I gotta be patient here I'm not exactly
a patient guy like sometimes it does the
extensions for you can attack this guy
it was awesome oh my god ah
less than 10 times thank you I miss less
than 10 times is that good or bad
good or bad around uh what bring it on
you bouche is Gucci's [ __ ] and
douches I'm not sure which one I
actually said examine to make that a new
and something everyone out there has
lifted right mouse buttons in the combat
zone green on you Boosh in this zone I
got it
bring it on you Bush oh my god he is
bloated and blood give me what it I want
that class
Wow speeches anybody if you're if you're
totally in it to win it
well you remember right when you start
insulting people instead of calling him
a douche or [ __ ] call them
pabu show ha ha ha ha go ski your eye
comes out now it's mine wah-wah-wah oh
hi mr. a man I'm really oh I'm not even
good at this game and it feels like I'm
amazing my favorite games are the ones
that have exceptionally simple concepts
and it's just a mastery of one skill
that I have a feeling why that was why
flappy bird was so popular because it
was so simplistic
you were just tapping and yet it was so
challenging and at the same time
simplistic but this has a simple concept
that you can do it master like I can get
better than this I know I know them what
now water in top two hits huh I gotta
forget about that watch out watch out
watch out
- look I'm gonna get 2.8 oh wow we're
guitar guitar I can't help but make
sound effects when I play this game cuz
betting rule this is literally like
watching those animations except you're
actually controlling it why did I not
know about this game sooner it's so epic
ah so great oh wow it's stylistically -
Wow am I like fist to the no sir except
not really but you know watch that anime
but I read the manga because I was
interested in it and I just like spam
through the whole thing and it was
actually pretty it got ridiculous
towards a minute but if you don't know
what Fist of the North Star is this is
one word he like has pressure point
knowledge and oh my god what is
happening oh my god swords he has
pressure point knowledge and he can like
I'm sewn in a certain spot in and makes
their whole body explodes really
interesting and weird and it get
ridiculous with the amount of power that
people had later on photo your enemies
by crushing the nip all right mouse
button J oh my god
what is happening whoa this is a
fantastical Oh God
I'm gonna need to change my pants after
I finish this game good lordy look at
all that the akio time thing about time
whoa whoa oh I'm so good
oh I'm so good oh so good
okay next time I'm gonna make sure that
I do not miss at all kero light sword
give me no light saber
you probably can't say lightsaber though
okay I'm not gonna miss enemies no mrs.
Jack's water enemies hit yata indicated
ow
I miss right off the bat I missed or at
all where how am I missing I thought
that took two hits
dammit Oh his horns that's what you get
breathing me [ __ ] walk yo I'm so much
fun
but the last time I played a game that I
had so am I supposed to actually beat
those guys
it's like it whoa whoa this face kind of
crazy as well isn't that the weapon that
that guy from Mortal Kombat use won't
come in three
we're guy always switches sides on me
that's what happens before time runs out
Butchie I get him suvamay awarded Riga I
don't want a starless kiss oh wow
Mattingly activated we're in the kill
requirement is a met what that's awesome
what about that excuse on and off each
acquit skill will become active while
playing a stage once you kill a certain
amount of enemies okay
three days activates after you kill one
it's so cool
boss level also longer between green and
the blue oh my god enemies yes [ __ ]
that's what happens yeah he switches
side sometimes cuz he dodges oh whoa I
missed
haha still there oh my god it's
difficult it's challenging gotta
concentrate watch out
come on bring on boss what how yeah oh
my god okay north or south I'll go doing
something MOG around
come on bring it on you [ __ ]
oh yeah ha ha
feel like I'm doing whoa here's flooded
oh that's right the three things and
right mouse buttons to shoot ball into
enemies any enemy in one hit
what about shooting him into the ball
back and forth oh I get it
damn it standing you're desperate all
right mouse button is on huh I lost my
ball someone want to get that back to me
y'all bow thank you
having fun I miss it here's my ball
making someone kicked my ball back to me
alright okay I think that actually might
be enough I'm gonna I'm gonna end it
here else I'm gonna play for like an
hour now one more one more
Gaddy one more time I'm under go insane
insane in the membrane with the kungfu
Oh get out oh you were so crazy
now yeah well now whip out oh you meant
behind us oh my ball hey they give me
the ball
that's what you get
you [ __ ] goo-goo-goo Bandidos man these
guys are getting tough there we go oh
yeah yeah whatever it's okay I had fun
that's all the matters okay so I'm done
that's it that's enough for me that's
enough for now I gotta figure out I know
I was only playing on the easy level and
I know that it was only playing for the
first time and I know that I was only
probably not that good at it
I still felt like a master ah either way
okay
that was totally unbelievably awesome
this game is available on Steam for five
bucks five bucks is all this game cost
that's how awesome it was I feel like
this game would work great for mobile
too because then you can just tap like
two ways either way fantastic game
click the link in the description below
I'll check out the description for more
amazing games that I played in the past
and as always I will see you did I thank
you for watching it in the next video
bye bye thank you